good afternoon the ukrainian president
has said a ukrainian and russian
delegation are to meet without
preconditions for peace talks on the
border between the two countries
russia's president putin has also
ordered his military command to put
nuclear deterrent forces on high alert
straight to our security and defense
editor deborah haynes who's in kiev um
deborah two things to look at there
let's start with these peace talks what
are they saying
yes it's a significant move and and also
we had from the beginning of the day
russia saying that it was sending
officials to belarus wanting to speak
with ukrainian uh the ukrainian side and
ukraine's president quickly coming out
and saying yes that they were prepared
to talk but not in a country like
belarus
where from where the russian invasion
was partially launched so it seems as
though there has been a bit of a
concession on the russian side to agree
to the fact that this this meeting is
happening actually on the border i don't
know if i'm reading that too much into
that or not but the fact as well is that
putin president putin is not going to be
in this from a position of particular
strength yes his forces have invaded
this country it's day four now of that
invasion and they have bombarded cities
across the nation but they have also met
surprisingly for them i think um stiff
ukrainian resistance on the ground and
then overwhelming resistance from the
western world
internationally i mean just take
germany's stance uh in terms of cutting
off this
multi-billion pound pipeline sending in
weapons saying it's going to send in
weapons to ukraine and today announcing
that it's going to significantly
increase its own defense budget also
lots of european nations shutting off
their airspace to russian planes and
cutting russian banks out of the
international financial system
significant body blows for the russian
president over his actions here but
these actions he sent this country into
crisis clearly the ukrainian president
needs this war to end but hopefully if
these negotiate negotiations are
happening
with the war in this current state then
he has a relatively strong hand to play
okay deborah um talk us through this
recent news that uh president putin has
ordered his military command to put
nuclear deterrent forces on quote high
alert
that sounds like he's upping the stakes
with an extremely aggressive move
yeah the word nuclear weapons makes
everyone shuddered doesn't it which is
not surprising but it's important to to
note that in russia's military doctrine
they actually use nuclear weapons
tactical nuclear weapons not strategic
uh ones that would cause you know sort
of armageddon in another country but
like a smaller nuclear weapon as a way
to de-escalate a conflict it's actually
literally part of their um doctrine to
win um but the fact that he is coming
out and making this very aggressive move
um it's clearly signaling to the west
that he uh you know reminding them not
that anyone needs reminding that he that
russia is a nuclear power and is willing
to use nuclear weapons but i mean the
idea that he might actually take that
step i think we
hopefully are a long way off from that
but the very fact it's even being raised
frankly to me uh does mark
smack a bit of of desperation on his
part um given that the war down here on
the ground doesn't seem to be going uh
in his direction and given the
overwhelming painful sanctions that he
has been hit with by western allies who
have actually gone much further than
people had initially thought especially
um with regards to germany and with
regards to other eu countries that have
traditionally got close ties or closer
than other european nations ties with
russia like italy for example